hello Ben Simon here with the chess club
were going to be looking at the
Invitational here today round number
three where a lot of action went down
here in day number two with the black
pieces Darwin yang had an exciting day
and an exciting win over Andre Diamont
well today uh my opponent Andre he plays
a lot of different openings and I knew
this but I played him several times
before so I I've kind of focused on what
we've already played and like in our own
games and but I also made sure to like
practice like my tactics and stuff
before the game I'm just like I can get
him playing shape but the way the way I
played it in the game was also fine I
think here he had to play f3 because the
idea is that if he plays King you won
back then I can still have this Bishop
d4 idea which I now saw and if he just
played f3 oh my
well my attacking his King would be a
lot weaker so instead I'd have to play
something like this and tried to use my
a3 pawn and it still would have been a
very unclear game but he made this
mistake King g3 which allowed a pretty
decisive finish because he didn't see
this move g5 and the real problem for
him is that he has all of his pieces on
this diagonal and I have a dark squared
bishop so the only thing I was really
protecting him
was this pawn on f4 but my playing g5 I
not only take it out but I also opened
the G file for my own rook and his King
is suddenly in a ton of trouble and he
tried to hold on to this defense but
in this position it looks really
precarious with all of his pieces are
aligned on the same diagonal and his
kiss King is just completely unprotected
so by playing this very subtle move rook
g8 which opened which threatens our
discovered attack on the G file all of
his defenses basically just break apart
and he tried to hang on for a little bit
but his King eventually just got
sandwiched on the H file and it was
checkmate after that so yang
middle-of-the-road
still a long way to go though for him as
we look at the GM standings I am Nima at
the head of the pack continuing his
tenure there defeating GM burrows today
with the black pieces technically not
that easy to win yes I mean I have a lot
of bonds there are many weaknesses I
mean yes but I mean there's to the long
value I have
I mean most likely I lose but I can at
least fight but after Queen c6 strong
move basically over and while we're not
reviewing any i.m games today let's take
a look at the standings we're at the end
of three set Homa with the clear lead
almost perfect for more information on
the tournament st. Louis chess club org
where you can find all of the recap
videos every day and we hope you join us
through Friday 11:00 a.m. and 5 p.m. are
the round times